foreign
let's go to Randy in Hanover what's up
Randy
hi Dr John so such an honor to speak
with you it's an honor to speak with you
hope you're doing well what's up
thank you so um
um thank you so my main question is real
good all right let's do it sorry sorry
I'm singing it's all right no it's good
to sing I think so too
so um the main question is if and if so
how there can be a healthy relationship
between screens and connectivity and
connection especially when it comes to
special needs families who often rely
heavily on technology and screens to
help address everything from chronic
chronic medical issues communication of
basic needs and daily task completion
and I have quite a bit of you know um
background for that as far as it relates
to our family if I could kind of
summarize that briefly of course um so
thank you so I grew up as an older
sister to a paralyzed sibling and she
used screens as an escape to experience
the world that was largely inaccessible
to her she still does I swore up and
down that my family would never have a
relationship like that with technology
that you fast forward
um a few years down the road and after a
very painful battle with infertility I
became a 23 year old new mom to a
23-week gestation 14 ounce micro preemie
and she thought yeah she fought for her
life in and out of state NICU with my
husband at her side while he was in
school and I was working full-time as a
nurse and I went to graduate school
full-time or my doctorate is a family
nurse practitioner and in that season
technology in the form of phone calls
and videos and pictures from my husband
were the only connection I had with my
daughter she had a seven percent chance
of survival but fast forward another
seven years down the road and now I'm an
independent clinician I work in a rural
community and I'm also a mom to that
seven things to that same little girl
she's seven years old she's a warrior
and a Survivor um she has severe
non-verbal autism she has an autoimmune
disease and she has seizures and so now
technology and electronic communication
Tech Systems videos games
um that's kind of been our only way to
really connect with her and that we've
found to break into her world and try to
bridge her into ours gradually my
husband and I really want more for our
family than a life tether Decor these
screens but we're completely overwhelmed
and a bit crushed by the situation we're
fighting really hard to try to build a
real life and trying to set guiding
routines and boundaries to encourage us
all to be more present but our daughter
struggles deeply to connect without
technology driven tools and often
screaming and violent meltdowns are what
results with us trying to disconnect
from them it leaves us exhausted and
more isolated than we already were so we
live in a really rural community limited
resources we're doing lots of therapies
we have counselors and she's an amazing
school system that's trying to help her
but actually a lot of the tools that the
school have are technology-based too so
we're grateful for the process the
progress she's made she had no words
until she was five she's just now
starting to use very simple sentences
wow
yeah it's a miracle we're so grateful
she's making better eye contact
um but she struggles with touch and
sensitivity and it's just a lot so I
actually know that from the work that I
do working with families I have a family
practice provider now and I see a lot of
children with autism this is a really
common problem and I just would love to
hear what your input would be are you
also asking me because I'm so outspoken
about screens
[Applause]
really truly deeply respect where you're
coming from I was raised without screens
my dad is passionate about that
um and I'm grateful for it I've gotten
experiences I never would have had
otherwise I had to learn technology in
order to go through school and grad
school it was kind of a lot for me
because I was so disconnected from it
and I I wanted more of that I saw what
my experience my sister had growing up
versus what I've had and then families
that have come in the past years and I
wanted to be different but you know
we're finding that
things don't always go exactly how we
wanted and um I've Loved a lot of things
that you've said but I've struggled to
try to find application for our
situation so we just wanted to get your
Insight
um so first and foremost thanks for
thanks for
doing such a great job articulating your
story and
um
here's what it sounds like to me number
one and I'll get to the screen stuff
it sounds like there literally is
nothing in the world you can't
accomplish
and you're like the nursing David
Goggins it's like 200 miles rice done
right in the middle of the night done
um there's nothing you can't put your
mind to and are you still married
yeah very happily it sounds like you're
gonna do this without him well I was
gonna say it sounds like you and your
husband it sounds like he's a gangster
too and together you are this
Unstoppable Force
and really in a
I wish there was a like a more
diplomatic way to say this but y'all
have the opportunity to impose your will
on the world
because you're both really smart you're
both really driven you both had
resources you both had great parents and
you both have figured out a way to do
just about whatever you want
and then you're in into this baby little
girl that
was possibly
um
outside of your sister
your first tangible grasp of oh I don't
control hardly anything and that's
that's it's unmooring right yeah it
we've tried you know we're like we'll
just stay in grad school we'll just
we'll keep pushing what we're doing and
I mean we did and then we've looked up
and we're like oh but like there was it
wasn't magic life is still actually
really hard the worst yes the worst and
here's what here's what here's what uh
it doesn't make it better I don't say
that or make it worse but you have a lot
of the answers
yeah and it's like you're looking you're
still looking through the glass like
when you have a newborn they're in that
little incubator thing
and you can see your baby but you can't
touch them
that's how you feel right now
because you've got all the answers you
know the X's and O's you're a you have
your own family practice you work with
people struggling and they come to you
for answers and then you turn to face
your own baby girl and you can't reach
to that glass and it feels powerless
yeah and it's scary right
absolutely and the people I love whose
kids have autism there are people who
are close to me
I can't think of I mean yes there's I
can think of a couple of things but
sometimes the only thing that
um
keeps me from just setting myself on
fire because my kids have driven me
crazy
is that moment when they curl up in my
lap
is touch
the ability to give touch and receive
touch and for kids who have high touch
sensitivities who
um are neural Divergent
it's like it's like you
it's like you're out to sea and every
third Breath You Take is underwater
because you're just bobbin out there
right
exactly I just want to hug my girl and I
can't because hugging her is the worst
thing for her and weirdly
physiologically it would probably be
helpful overall to body inflammation and
to neural regulation and all the
polyvagles it would help but it can't
yep and so we just sit there and we
drown together and it's me I'm I'm
heartbroken with you but I want you to
hear me say I hear you okay
thank you thank you I really appreciate
that take all the crap I've said about
screens and take it out in the backyard
and bury it with a big pile of horse
Cha-Cha right
is that cool
yes technology is incredible
and I often say things to hit the
pendulum
because people are frozen in certain
paradigms
I've got friends who play travel Sports
and their kids are amazing and they've
chosen travel Sports and they live it
and they love it and they would want no
other things and it's the parents job to
put some breaks on that but I fully
support it
and there's millions of other parents
who use travel Sports as a way to prop
themselves up
right right similar with screens when I
left ready for my dirty little secret
when I left the office this morning
my son managed to pull off straight A's
this semester how he did that I don't
know I don't know because I know his
grades were in the last week before I
don't know how it happened
but he did
and he also got up before God was awake
this morning and did all of his his his
far I call him his farm chores his banjo
chores he was out there with the
chickens and getting the dogs set up and
getting all the water and it's freezing
with it when I left the house he had
done everything
he was playing his old we
a video game America my kid was playing
a video game
okay
and
um he had earned that right and it's
we're paying close attention to it he's
not playing online games with strangers
who are grooming him for things and he's
got an hour he's got a time limit
but I want you to hear me say
um
you are doing what you can to breathe
and you mentioned it a couple of times I
want to call it out you and your husband
want these things to be different and
right now they're not
and so at some point your path to
Wellness is not to continue to go to war
with reality it's to accept its own
reality this is for us right now I think
that makes a lot of sense and so the
here's the magic here's how you do that
it's the awful G word you have to grieve
it
and every time you run up against
something that says hey we wanted to
but we can't
you hear how I said that like I I really
want to go on experiences and go out and
put the stupid phones down and go
outside
but we can't
because we're on the razor's edge of
another meltdown and I can't do another
meltdown tonight
right and so um for 13 seconds I'm gonna
go
my husband doesn't suck I don't suck my
daughter doesn't suck this just sucks
and then I'm gonna exhale real deeply
I'm gonna drop my shoulders and then I'm
gonna head back in and fire it up dude
let's get let's get connected
that's super helpful because I don't
want to hurt her with what we do but
I've seen it help in so many ways you
know when we started she didn't make eye
contact and now she
takes it out and she asks us to you know
she'll bring us into whatever game she's
playing because that's just what speaks
to her and she she's starting to really
grow beyond that and I want to try to
bridge it and find ways to connect with
her and she's even you know she has
struggled with touch but now it started
off in the middle of the night she'd
push up her hands underneath us because
she sleeps in bed with us a lot because
of the seizures and so we would find
like when she wasn't even conscious of
it she was seeking it and then now
she'll come and ask us to hold her
sometimes and to hug her and so I've
seen it grow and it's just little when
we can capture it and so if there's ways
to try to bring her back into
you know outside and world and not the
screen I want to do that but I tried I
tried just cold turkey I'm gonna go and
just give her screen time and then try
to have it otherwise but it took away
her voice I mean that's how she talks to
us and so don't take that from her that
was
I was trying to build on what we do have
because it's just these little tiny
moments be so grateful that you live in
this weird sliver of History where they
got this all this stuff they could just
be in your house right
right this stuff that was more powerful
than what they put people on the moon
with the computers they used and now we
have them all over our house everywhere
great right so it's a it's a moment to
celebrate it's a season to celebrate and
you're seeing the fruits here's what
like when it comes to screens here's
what I'm I'm I am super against
I'm against digital babysitters
I'm against parents opting out of their
children's lives or their romance their
partner's lives now we've got grown-ups
playing video games all the time who do
it as a way to occupy their kids so that
they don't have to interact with their
kids so they can do more quote unquote
important things that is not what you
are doing
in fact screens are a connection tool
and I have looked at some of the
research and I've got to be humble to it
because I'm not above scientific
literature I'm just not and
parents who play video games with their
kids together
um man there's some pretty neat
connections that happen there
that's awesome I have to own that I wish
it wasn't the case I wish it only was
dad's out playing soccer with their it's
not real okay the deal is connection
the deals connection the deal's
connection and this these These are
proving to be these technological
advancements are proving to be an Avenue
of connection for you and your kid take
them take them take them okay thank you
so much for that that means a lot be at
peace be at peace and every once in a
while try cold turkey try say hey let's
go outside
but you'll feel it gunning up and you'll
be like nope turn it around going back
inside and we're gonna give it a shot
right or maybe we move um we get one of
those cheap
TV Roku things we put on the front porch
and we that way we're watching TV
outside maybe that's a way we can slowly
integrate it in
we do we have we have
a porch we do actually do that way ahead
of the game listen can I tell you your
baby girl won the freaking Lottery
getting you his mom no thank you that
means a lot can I also say one more
thing that you didn't that you can just
say hey you edit that out you piece of
crap can I say one more thing
yes please she's not your fault
thank you she's not that means a lot
that means a lot I want you to set that
down you didn't do this to her
thank you I just need to hear that I
don't know how you knew but I I did need
that
you'll need to hear that over and over
and over and over you did not do this to
her
foreign
selected you
and you and your husband are doing an
incredible job of loving this little
girl
ah thank you you
understand when my little girl comes in
and pinches me or just she just wax me
for some reason I don't understand it
like her love language is Bam
I will remember this conversation that I
had with you
because
um I can't imagine what you'd give up to
have your daughter come in and just grab
you
right yeah I take it for granted and you
get the I can't imagine if my kid
started shoving their hands under my
back while I was sleeping
I would like chop them off and for you
it is this it was it was a it was a it
was a moment directly from God himself
right it was a moment of connection
peace and so you are living a life
you're you're getting to see Life Below
life right and it's a gift
this is not your fault
it's not by your hand but it's in your
lap and you're doing a really amazing
job okay thank you so much I I truly
appreciate it I I could I was trying to
guess what you would say and this is not
what it was so
thank you the Insight is amazing truly I
appreciate it and it helps a lot thank
you awesome
um now your husband's gonna take this
he's gonna go wanna buy all the Grand
Theft Autos not what I'm saying
but I don't know I don't even mind for
him fair enough y'all are putting the
time y'all are putting the time in right
now I'm in no place to tell y'all what
to do anything y'all get through your
days the best you can and please do this
make sure you check in with each other
you and your husband make sure you all
stay connected to this whole journey
Stay Together
God y'all are amazing I'm honored to
have gotten to spend some time with you